est-ce que tu regardes les émissions de
cuisine tôt parce que je sais que toi un
coup de gueule là dessus oui j'ai un
coup de gueule comme violent fait par
exemple l'émission top chef je voudrais
bien qu'ils mettent des barrières qu'ils
ne fassent pas rentrer n'importe qui
enfin je suis pareil avec l'autre jour
quelqu'un sur le plateau qui est le
directeur du guide michelin mais tu te
rends compte ces gens là qui mais c'est
incroyable alors le guide michelin en
plus allons nommer avait expliqué pour
les téléspectateurs sont d y aller il ya
des personnes qui se rendent dans des
restaurants anonymat nino anonymement
c'est un peu comme dans le film en film
avec celle où l'accusé
savait qu'avec tricatel voilà et c'est
vrai que voilà et donc qui viennent
noter les restaurants parce que c'est
extrêmement important il ya des gens
quand ils perdent une étoile au guide
michelin c'est leur vie s'écroule et ben
voilà et bien voilà donc vous avez tout
dit cyril vous avez tout dit il la
harcèle je dis bien je pèse bien mes
mots les assène le cuisinier pour
obtenir une étoile et il le harcèle il
est encore harceler pour la maintenir
mais je sais je trouve ça c'est vraiment
exagéré une pression il ya des liens
c'est pas possible c'est de prédire moi
y avait donc ça cesse et maintenant avec
les réseaux sociaux ça va s'arranger un
cuisinier mais les jeux ne trouvait plus
à tous les jeunes ne veulent plus tout
ça parce que je n'aurai plus est et qui
a mis une telle pression de perdre ses
étoiles qui voit là acquis qu'ils
avaient faim service était tragique
histoire un putsch en essai à saulieu à
trajet qu'il va et fernand l'oiseau
enfin bien sûr et pas qu'il ya une telle
pression pour les cuisiner d'avoir cette
étoile michelin c'est une étoile deux
étoiles ou trois fois quand ils perdent
leur étoile c'est si si c'est tout moi
j'ai vécu des scénarios vous avez eu
deux fois trois étoiles c'est vraiment
une fois trois étoiles de fort 20 sur 20
là j'ai pas de s'écouter naturellement
on va venir tu te dis que le guide
michelin guide michelin est encensé un
moment ben oui bien sûr mais c'est le
vin sur vin qui nous encensait vos amis
à qui est le gault et millau et le gault
et millau je vous dire parce que je ne
supporte pas chez le michelin c'est
qu'en fait ils viennent de manière
sournoise vous noté
ils se font connaître ou pas comme
maintenant ils n'ont pas suffisamment
d'inspecteurs il délègue une partie de
la clientèle pour noter c'est absolument
odieux moi je le dis c'est pour ça que
les jeunes n'en veut par contre vous
savez le gault et millau je veux pas
faire l'apologie du gault et millau mais
julien deloire ils ont sorti un livre
qui s'appelle le sang neuf
ce guide est populaire les menus 135
euros vous en avais sur toute la france
sans ma fille son sang neuf et c'est du
sang neuf il régénère c'est populaire
c'est gastronomique et c'est fort et moi
je leur dis bravo alors ce que le
michelin va passer de conduite la route
est toujours un chapeau marque à bas la
pause c'est une autre histoire en deux
mois mon grand père était communiste
anticlérical à manigod dans mon petit
beau il y avait l'école des curés avec
avec 40 40 membres il y avait les soeurs
avec une vingtaine de filles et mon père
est un communiste mon grand-père est
encore ici a dit jamais ça donc il a
fait venir les collègues il a mis à six
kilomètres donc à cinq ans et demi s'il
voulait nous les enfants des enfants
n'étaient pas en était qu une partie de
la famille puisque personne n'y allait
et on faisait 6 km y avait pas de
ramassage scolaire matin et soir et j'ai
une histoire formidable histoire d'amour
que je raconte toujours pourquoi ce
chapeau parce que mon grand père était
berger il avait une centaine de moutons
et de chèvres et au bout d'un moment il
a dîné au régime effectivement ce j'ai
trop j'ai trop peur et pour ça c'est
dommage non je vais accompagner le pied
donc il m'accompagne à l'école avec le
troupeau de moutons qui mangeaient les
talus et a sorti de l'école il était
assis au milieu de la prairie avec les
moutons autour six chiens et qu'est ce
qu'il y avait sur le chapeau parce qu'il
avait son chapeau et bien mais les
fraises des bois qui venait de ramasser
les framboises leur style et les choses
merveilleuses et sas c'est inoubliable
c'est un acte d'amour donc c'est pour ça
je ne verse rien à voir tout à fait la
cuisine moi je crois que tu es que
geneviève de fontenay
je suis posé la question excusez moi
voilà je te plait je te pose la question
les 10 millions de wii donc masterchef
ça marche pas on voulait juste voilà que
tu viens de nous voir marc voilà pour
dire ça parce que c'est vrai que tu à
venir à coups de gueule aux émissions de
cuisine et si tu veux revenir nous voir
c'est quand tu veux marque pour parler
d'acte humain qui peut parler de tout
armement avec beaucoup de plaisir bien
sûr tout ce que je voudrais qu'on parle
surtout qu'on prenne conscience que
toute cette jeunesse qui est là prennent
conscience de l'alimentation
c'est jonas et déjà morts
parce qu'ils ont mangé de salsifis qui
vont venir un tony faut pas plaisanter
là dessus la nourriture écoute je
connais bien depuis l'équipe que tu
étais un un footballeur mais je crois
que c'est essentiel si on est tous là
c'est grâce à l'alimentation mais si on
n'est plus là demain c'est aussi en
partie la responsabilité de
l'alimentation qu'on consomme avec
n'importe quoi on est d'accord donc je
dis simplement une chose les jeunes
prenez conscience que l'alimentation
c'est votre sphère de la rentrée votre
carburant et si vous n'avez pas pris
conscience que la nourriture en général
sort de la terre pour monter vers le
ciel il ya un côté spirituel dans la
nourriture et la faveur pendant qu
[Applaudissements]